Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain an American romantic
fantasy film called “The Age Of Adaline.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The protagonist of the movie
is a twentynine-year-old woman
named Adaline Bowman. In the beginning, she
walks into an apartment and buys a fake ID
under a different name. She returns back home to
feed her dog then goes to work. It is a normal
day in San Francisco for Adaline until her
coworker hands her archives containing reels
of historical events. Adaline excitedly agrees
to sort through them and brings the box home.
She sets up a projector and watches videos
of the historic times in fascination. It is
narrated that Adaline was actually born on
January 1st, 1908. In 1929, she married a
young man named Clarence James and only three
years later, she gave birth to a baby girl,
Fleming. Adaline was happiest she could ever be
but her life turned upside down when her husband
died in a tragic accident during the construction
of the Golden Gate Bridge in 1937.
Ten months after her husband’s death, Adaline
was driving to her parent’s cottage. That night,
snow fell in the otherwise dry Sonoma County,
California. Adaline had poor visibility on the
road because of the snowfall which caused her to
crash into a ravine. Tragically, she died freezing
in water but something magical happened next. She
was struck by lightning and brought back to life.
And from that moment onwards, Adaline hasn’t
aged a second. As she grew older, she realized
she had this unique condition but thought it was
because of a good diet, exercise, and simple luck.
But as time passed, her appearance at her age
became almost abnormal. Her daughter Fleming
grew older and the two started looking
like sisters but Adaline didn’t age.
One day, she is pulled over by a policeman
for a minor traffic inconvenience but the
man doesn’t believe she is forty-five years old.
This makes Adaline realize she cannot live with
her condition. Hence, she moves to San Francisco
from her suburban neighborhood to study medicine
and research her condition. However, even after
a year of research, she acquires little to no
information about her condition. She is eventually
forced to accept the fact that there is no
scientific explanation for why she doesn’t
age. One night while returning home, she is
approached by FBI agents who suspect her of being
a spy because of lack of record of residence.
They pull over their car by a plane and taking
the opportunity, Adaline flees from the place.
Starting then, she has always been on a run,
moving from state to state and changing her
name every few years. It is currently 2014 and
Adaline is one hundred six years old but neither
her appearance nor her health has changed since
she was twenty-nine. Her daughter Fleming has aged
gradually and looks old enough to be Adaline’s
mother. Currently, she is living as Jennifer
Larson and is about to move in seven weeks
under a different name. On her 107th birthday,
Adaline’s blind friend Regan invites her to a new
year's eve party. Adaline dresses up beautifully
and arrives at a lavish mansion. There, she sees
decades-old pictures of herself and reminisces
about her friends. Adaline meets Regan who
jokes about only younger men liking her,
unknown that she doesn’t age.
While they talk, Adaline locks eyes
with a handsome young man across the room named
Ellis Jones. They exchange a few glances but do
not talk throughout the night. When the clock
hits midnight, Adaline is about to leave when
Ellis joins her in the elevator. They introduce
themselves and get to know more about each other.
Adaline introduces herself as Jennifer, trying
to stay as away from him as possible. It is clear
that Ellis is more interested in her than she is
in him. He awkwardly escorts her out and asks her
how they can meet again but Adaline leaves after
wishing him a happy new year. The following day,
she goes to meet Fleming for lunch. The mother
and daughter hug and have a happy conversation.
Flemings tells Adaline about her plan to
move into a retirement home somewhere far
which Adaline is not happy about because she
wants to stay closer to her daughter.
The next day, Adaline is surprised to see Ellis
walk into her work. He has somehow found out where
she works and has brought her books as gifts.
This time, he bravely asks her out on a date,
and seeing the man try so hard, Adaline agrees.
She asks him to take her to a place she has never
been before in San Francisco. Ellis accepts the
challenge and takes her to the recently found
historic tunnel. An impressed Adaline asks him
many questions but when it’s her turn to talk
about herself, she only mentions that she has a
dog. Before leaving, Adaline tells him about her
plans to move to a different state soon. Hearing
this Ellis asks her out on a second date and makes
her accept it after telling an awful joke.
In the following scene, Adaline goes to Ellis’s
apartment for their date. Ellis surprises
her again with his innovative dish.
The two have a wonderful conversation while
drinking wine and listening to jazz music. Ellis
tells her about his father who is an astronomer
and is famous for discovering an unusual comet.
He also reveals that the new year’s party wasn’t
when he first saw Adaline. In fact, he had first
seen her a while ago sitting near the library in
a blue dress and instantly felt drawn to her.
The two look into each other’s eyes and
move closer to kiss but Adaline pulls away,
refusing to act on her feelings. She is afraid
to be close to anyone since she is always moving
and changing her identities. Ellis hides
his disappointment and asks her more about
herself. His words overwhelm Adaline and
the two finally kiss. The following morning,
they wake up on Ellis’s bed. As Adaline goes to
work that day, she passes a park and remembers the
time a man was waiting for her on the same park
bench. It was her lover from a long time ago who
wanted to marry her but Adaline had to leave
him because of her condition. Later, Adaline
walks home to her dog lying limp on the floor.
She rushes him to the vet and finds out that his
kidneys have failed so it would be best to put him
down. Later, Adaline returns home distressed and
looks at an album with the pictures of dogs she
has had over the years. At night, she is walking
to her apartment when Ellis approaches her with a
bouquet of flowers. He had left her several voice
mails which she didn’t answer so he went out of
his way to figure out her address from her work.
Adaline informs him about her dog’s death and
tells him he shouldn’t have invaded her privacy.
She leaves abruptly after asking him to stay
away. The following day, she meets Fleming
again and tells her about Ellis. Fleming advises
her mother to let go and live her life for once.
Adaline feels sorry for being rude to Ellis the
other day and goes to his work to apologize.
The two then go out for a date at
night. This time, Adaline takes him to
a drive-in movie theater from the sixties.
She passionately explains the history of the
theater to an impressed Ellis. They get in one of
the cars and watch the stars drawn on the ceiling.
Ellis then invites her for another date to
his parents’ house for their 40th anniversary.
Adaline agrees in the condition that she will
be driving. The next day, they drive to Ellis’s
parent’s home and pick up Ellis’s sister Kikki
on the way. When the three finally reach there,
they are welcomed by Ellis’s parents, William
and Kathy. As soon as William sees Adaline,
he says her name. Adaline is in shock but corrects
him saying that her name is Jennifer. The two
share awkward eye contact after which Adaline
claims that William must have known her mother.
Willam is visibly shaken seeing how much
Jennifer looks like his old friend Adaline,
hence, he is in uttermost shock when Jennifer
tells him Adaline passed away a few years ago.
After everyone goes to sleep, William pours him
a glass of wine and reminisces about the time he
first met Adaline. He was only twenty-six years
old and she was twenty-nine when he helped her
fix her car. The two instantly got along and even
though Adaline went by the name Della at the time,
she told William her real name. The two quickly
fell in love and traveled to America together.
It is then revealed that William was the man
who was about to propose to Adaline at the park
but Adaline got to know about it and stood him
up. She actually loved him but couldn’t risk her
secret being out. Back in the present, Adaline
cannot fall asleep at night. In the breakfast,
Williams again brings up Adaline and
talks about how nice of a person she was.
His face lights up when he talks about her and
as he praises her, his wife Kathy gets up and
walks away. Williams goes behind her to ask
her what is wrong and finds out that she feels
like a second option to him after Adaline.
He reassures her he loves her and the two kiss.
The day passes and at night, the family gathers
for a game. They have a tradition of playing a
tabletop trivia game that William has a 47 game
winning record. As the family talks, Kikki says
that the comet William discovered is called
Della. The family believes that the name is set
after William’s aunt but Adaline realizes he named
it after her. She holds her tears and continues
playing the game with the family. She eventually
beats William’s record and wins the game,
surprising everyone. A while later, Adaline goes
out for a walk and is startled by William who is
stargazing. The two have a nice chat and William
tells her he was about to propose to her mother.
Before leaving Adaline also confesses that
her mother loved him no matter what.
In the following scene, Adaline is back in
bed with Ellis. He eventually confesses he
has fallen in love with her and cannot imagine
his life without her in it. She smiles but
doesn’t say I love you back. The next morning,
Adaline goes for a walk and runs into William.
He sees a ladybug on her head and helps her
remove it. While he is at it, William notices
a scar on Adaline’s wrist that is identical
to the one that his girlfriend Adaline had.
He remembers it clearly because he was the
one who stitched the wound for her and even
has a picture of them together where Adaline’s
hand is bandaged. He finally confronts her and
asks her for the truth. Adaline comes clean
and tells him she doesn’t know how it started
but she doesn’t age. She also admits that
her condition was the reason she left him.
William asks her if she will leave his son as
well. Adaline gets overwhelmed at the question
and runs back to the house in a hurry.
She quickly packs her bags and leaves a
note for Ellis who is still in the shower. Like
always, Adaline has decided to run away so she
wouldn’t hurt anyone. She takes his car keys and
drives away as William tries to stop her. When
Ellis comes out of the shower, he is heartbroken
to see the note. He gets dressed and asks William
what he said to Adaline. William just says that
she is not ready for the change. He asks his son
if he actually loves Adaline. Ellis says he does
because nothing in life makes sense without her
even though he hasn’t known her for long. Hearing
this, William hands his car key to Ellis urging
him to go look for Adaline. Ellis calls Adaline
numerous times on his way but she ignores all his
calls. She pulls over her car coincidentally,
near the same place her accident took places
decades ago. Adaline reminisces about
the times she has run away from life
and realizes she loves Ellis too much to stay
without him. She then calls Fleming and tells
her she is going to settle in life. However, after
the call, Adaline gets hit by a speeding car.
Her body lies limp by the side of the road and
for the first time in 78 years, it snows in Sonoma
County. As the temperature drops, Adaline
freezes and her heartbeat eventually stops.
Just then, Ellies arrives there and performs
CPR to try to bring her back. A while later,
the paramedics arrive at the scene and place
2 defibrillator paddles on Adaline's chest.
They administer 750 volts of electricity, similar
to the one she had gotten when the lightning
struck her decades ago. Because of it, she finally
takes a breath and is brought back to life.
In the following scene, Adaline is in the
hospital with Ellis. He apologizes for
saying I love you too fast but Adaline kisses
him, claiming that she loves him too. She then
opens up about her condition to him and reveals
that she is actually 107 years old. Strangely,
Ellis is calm even after hearing the truth.
It is now a year later. Ellis and Adaline are
a happy couple living together. Adaline even
has a new puppy that Fleming looks after most
of the time. One night, the couple plans to go
out to a New Year’s party. While getting ready,
Adaline notices a single grey hair on her
head. The movie ends as it is revealed that
she has started to age again.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.